welcome back to las vegas now today is a
day to celebrate love but february can
be a whole month dedicated to
celebrating love clark county and the
marriage license bureau are rolling out
a lot of fun initiatives and here to
tell us more is clark county clerk lynn
goya thank you so much for being here
thank you for having me it's so great to
see you again and it's so much fun to
talk about what you guys have planned
where do we even start for the month of
february
well the commission declared february as
wedding month so that's happened at the
beginning of the month
we rolled out an app that we're
investing in the community so that
couples can go to the app it's pass at
5millionlovestories.com or go to
5millionlovestories.com
sorry go to 5 million love stories on
weddings.vegas and you can sign up for
the app and if you're a business that
would like to say thank you to couples
you can sign up for that as well so
what's the inspiration behind 5 million
love stories i love it well clark county
since it was founded in 1909 is about to
issue its 5 millionth wedding license
and that's going to come up in the next
few weeks so we're very excited about
that and obviously we wanted to make a
big deal about it and um you know invite
the community to celebrate with us yeah
that's a huge milestone and as you know
i got married a few months ago so i
spent a lot of time down at the bureau
and learning a lot about everything that
you guys do and you make it just so easy
and fun to get all the information that
you need you know in order to do it
properly and you just really want to
reward couples that have chosen to get
married in las vegas right absolutely if
you're 5 million licensed then there are
5 million couples before you so we want
to say thank you to the couples that
chose las vegas and let's talk about
this mural this is something really
exciting i think we have some pictures
of it tell us all about it so the mural
just went up a couple days ago this is
something that we've been trying to get
for quite a long time
we got permission from the county and
it's on a government building so that
took some effort
but we reached out to jerry misko and
this is his creation and we just love it
the colors are all bright
he has an original picture that no one
else has seen his uncle was actually one
of the people that created the cake and
so he had pictures from that time and
used that as part of the mural how cool
just a way to brighten up las vegas and
it's so beautiful and so fun and really
quickly i know you guys have been
working hard on this you just unveiled
your new website as well right we did
weddings.vegas and hopefully that will
help people get through the process more
easily we always want to make it as
quick and easy to get your information
as possible and obviously that
weddings.vegas is easier to remember
than clarkcountynv.gov
clerk so that's a good thing and then we
have again
a special
keepsake that we're a lot that we're
launching in february so we like to do
something special for the couples that
want that and then the envelope that
they'll get all their paperwork in we'd
have that printed as well so we think
that's really cute it reflects that
mid-century modern
style that i think reflects las vegas
that's so cool i love that you mix it up
i think i have the one with the showgirl
on it so you never know what's going to
pop up each month that's really great
lynn thank you so much thank you for
filling us in on all of this and they're
such a great and helpful source so we
really appreciate it